resuelve el sistema de ecuaciones
graficando verifica tu solución
algebraica mente gráfica hemos cada una
de estas voy a usar un color oscuro para
que resalte voy a graficar esta ecuación
de arriba con azul esta parábola lo
primero que hay que pensar es si abre
hacia arriba o hacia abajo espera
primero como sé que es una parábola la
razón es que es una ecuación cuadrática
aquí tenemos un término de segundo orden
y ahora tenemos que considerar si la
parábola abre hacia arriba o abre hacia
abajo como puedes ver el término cuadra
tico tiene un coeficiente negativo así
es que la parábola abre hacia abajo y
dónde va a estar su valor máximo
pensemos en esto por un momento este
término de aquí siempre va a ser
negativo o más bien va a ser no positivo
x cuadrada es siempre positivo y con
este signo menos va a ser siempre un
término negativo así es que el valor
máximo de esta expresión va a ocurrir
cuando este término se hace cero el
valor máximo se hace cuando este término
se hace cero así es que el vértice de
esta parábola se ubica en x 0 igual a 6
así es que x es igual a series 1 2
3 4 5 6 aquí está el vértice el cual
corresponde al punto más alto de la
parábola podemos graficar un par de
puntos más para ver cómo es esta
parábola veamos entonces qué pasa cuando
x es igual a 2 voy a hacer una tabla por
acá aquí vamos a poner los valores de x
empezamos con x igualados y aquí los
valores de y menos x cuadrada más 6 así
es que cuando x es igual a 2 tenemos que
x al cuadrado es 4 con este signo menos
es menos 4 + 6 lleva a ser igual a 2 y
cuando x es igual a menos 2 va a ser lo
mismo pues menos 2 elevado al cuadrado
es 4 con el signo menos es menos 4 y más
6 también nos da 2 tenemos esos puntos
el punto 2 2 y el punto menos 2,2 menos
2,2 y ahora para graficar esto
calculemos otros puntos con 3 y equis es
igual a 3 sería 3 al cuadrado es 9 con
el signo menos menos 96 sería menos 3 y
si x es igual a menos 3 es lo mismo
menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 con el signo
menos es menos 96 es menos 3
practiquemos entonces estos puntos el
punto menos 3 3 aquí lo tenemos y el
punto 3 como a menos 3 ya tenemos un
buen número de puntos entonces podemos
graficar nuestra parábola aquí viene
nuestra parábola no no me gusta mucho
voy a volverla a hacer
aquí viene nuestra parábola y luego aquí
llega el vértice baja no tengo problemas
con la segunda parte baja por acá no
déjame hacer lo mejor de abajo hacia
arriba vamos a conectar los puntos y ahí
tenemos la parábola no creo que puedo
hacerla mejor vamos a hacerla un poco
mejor que pase bien por los puntos ahora
sí ahora sí ya tenemos la parábola
seguiría en esa dirección y así es como
se ve la primera ecuación gráfica mos la
segunda ecuación que es igual a menos 2
x menos 2
esto es una recta es una ecuación lineal
la mayor potencia que encontramos es 1
entonces nuestra ordenada al origen es
menos 2012 aquí está nuestro orden al
origen y ahora la pendiente de menos 2
si avanzamos 1 a la derecha vamos a
bajar 2 si avanzamos 2 a la derecha
vamos a bajar 2 veces menos 2 así es que
vamos a bajar 4 ahora si avanzamos 2 a
la izquierda
vamos a subir 4 y ahí parece que ya
encontramos uno de los puntos de
intersección vamos a dibujar la línea
la línea se va a ver algo así me es
difícil hacer la mano aquí déjame hacer
mi mejor intento esto va a ir algo así
caray parece que tengo en tu vida la
mano vamos a hacerla por acá se va a ver
algo algo así ahí está y la pregunta es
donde se intersectan estas dos gráficas
uno de los puntos de intersección ya
apareció y apareció cuando trazamos las
gráficas es este punto menos 2,2 este es
el punto que apareció cuando hicimos las
gráficas el punto menos 2,2 y veamos si
es correcto esto si ponemos menos 2 aquí
en la recta menos 2 x menos dos es
cuatro menos dos es dos y si lo ponemos
en la parábola es menos 46 es igual a 2
así es que está correcto y va a parecer
otro punto por acá abajo donde también
se intersectan las gráficas veamos
cuando x es igual a 4 cuando x es igual
a 4 esto va a ser 4 al cuadrado 16 menos
16 6 esto va a ser igual a menos 10
grafique molo aquí tenemos 4 y tenemos
12 3
5 6 7 8 9 10 aquí tenemos el punto
parece que ese es el otro punto de
intersección déjame extender la parábola
para acá abajo y si efectivamente el
otro punto intersección parece que es
ese si seguimos esta línea roja parece
que se intersecta y veamos si se
verifica esto 4 como menos 10 ya sabemos
que está en la línea azul
veamos si está también en la línea roja
tenemos menos 2 x 4 - 2 - 2 x 4
8 - 2 esto es menos 10 así es que
efectivamente el punto el punto 4 coma
menos 10 está en ambas gráficas cuando x
es igual a 4 y es igual a menos 10 para
las dos gráficas así es que ambos puntos
definitivamente son los puntos de
intersección